huile sucre conserves pâtes et
consommateurs font des stocks exemple
pour l'huile et le sucre plus 100% dans
ce supermarché faire des stocks une
réaction fréquentes dans les situations
d'urgence
[Musique]
1991 en pleine guerre du golfe les
français des valisettes déjà les
réunions
j'achète tout en double surtout les
personnes âgées qu'ils ont déjà passé
par là et m'ont dit surtout
prévoyez alors les consommateurs
redoutaient alors les pénuries comme ça
s'ils voulaient qu'on crée des psychoses
après-vente le manque de tout en france
c'est un autre exemple en 1976
cet été là les alsaciens cédaient aussi
à la panique ne faites pas comme ce
consommateur mal informées il craint une
éventuelle pénurie de sucre et se
constitue des réserves pour y paraît
dans la région une sécheresse
exceptionnelle mettait à mal la
production de sucre par peur de manquer
les consommateurs faisaient aussi des
stocks
les gens se précipitent sur les papiers
de sucre
vous donner un exemple on peut vendre
actuellement on peut vendre une tonne de
sucre en une demi heure
ce qui est vraiment anormal autre vent
de panique en mai 1968
ben tu t'imposes provisions parce que
j'ai jamais ce qui peut arriver quoi
faso grève qui paralysait le pays
les français faisait le plein peut-on
savoir ce qu'on m'a acheté le plus vient
surtout de des pâtes de la farine de
l'huile sur voyez ce que la ménagère se
sert de cela pour nom des gens qui
m'oblige un petit peu acheté parce que
je veux que tout le monde achète et
bientôt ils eurent green les magasins
pourtant pour le responsable du magasin
aucune raison de s'inquiéter
nous attendons ce 1 tonne de riz tout à
l'heure il y a une chose possible c'est
que peut-être ils n'auront pas toutes
les qualités
par exemple en sucre il est possible que
nous manquions de certains sucre en
morceaux mais enfin
je crois que les jours prochains ne
manquons pas de marchandises un discours
similaire aujourd'hui le gouvernement la
sueur pas de risque de pénurie
alimentaire en france
[Musique]